hey youtubers is charlie huge news flash
rebirth in the comics dropped this week
so I'm going to explain what's going on
with that storyline in the flash season
3 just announced a new character that
it's casting like a really big character
so I'll start with that so the new
season 3 character is being described as
a major recurring character meaning
they're going to come back a lot like
patty was a major recurring character
for the first half of the season so
somebody that's at least as big of a
character as patty in the way the
description reads the casting
description it's going to be a male
character but it sounds like it's not
going to be a villain someone that will
end up being a friend so it says they're
looking for berries slightly older
slightly geekier contemporary a guy who
is as smart as he is intuitive as such
this newcomer doesn't buy berries nice
guy routine and sets out to learn what
he's hiding all the while concealing
some secrets of his own so it sounds
like he's going to be a detective type
who will end up being a friend but is
just very suspicious of Barry doesn't
know he's the flash right away so when
they're saying he's suspicious of
Barry's nice guy routine you have like
the bumbling awkward Barry then you have
the slightly more badass flash persona
although buried like the line between
Barry Allen and the flash isn't quite as
stark is the line between Bruce Wayne
and Batman so like Barry's personality
doesn't change a whole lot when he puts
on the flash costume he's essentially
the same person but when you're thinking
about major characters like this think
about comic book characters that would
have the most impact and would tie in
with some of the other big storylines
now it doesn't say that this character
is going to crossover with the other
shows but what I'd like to think is that
they're going to introduce someone like
arrow introduced mr. terrific someone
who's capable of crossing over into
Justice Society story so there are a
couple characters they could do right
away I like the idea that the show would
do max mercury at some point I mean we
have mercury labs so he's kind of always
been around but we really don't know
what's going on with mercury labs and I
like him a little bit more as a villain
because I don't think that they'll just
keep bringing on more speedsters I think
they'll try to mix the formula up this
season but the closest person I could
think of off the top of my head that
would be really awesome for them to do
would be the Wesley Dodds Sandman
because he's a scientist he has a
genius-level intellect and he's part of
the
Society so they could introduce a
version of him like arrow introduced mr.
terrific someone who hasn't quite
achieved their full potential and then
he could make the mask over the course
of the season become part of the Justice
Society in future episodes but here's
another big reason why I really like
Sandman because he appeared on the 1990
flash series in that series is really
big about bringing characters back when
it can now obviously it wouldn't be the
same actor to play the role because when
the casting description reads he'll be
Berry's contemporary that means he'll be
close to Barry's age but a little bit
older so think somebody closer to
Stephen Amell zay just like a couple
years older than Barry because Barry's
supposed to be in his mid-20s so i'll
put the casting description up here for
the character again let me know in the
comments who do you think this character
is remember major character probably
someone from the comics maybe potential
to be used in a big Justice Society for
night crossover story so no idea who
they're going to cast only that it's
going to be a male character probably
from the comics just a few years older
than Barry now just remember it doesn't
matter how old a character is in the
comics because the TV show always
changes people's ages a little bit but
if they just introduced our man on
legends of tomorrow it just it makes
sense that they would start filling out
that table of Justice Society characters
if this first new person actually does
end up being a villain that he could
totally be dr. alchemy who's one of the
Rogues he works in the crime lab with
Barry so you could see how he'd be
nerdier than Barry but he's also hiding
a secret Allah The Alchemist so dr.
alchemy just another big pick but that's
only the first character obviously
there's going to be a ton of new
characters in season 3 they haven't said
anything about the villain yet so as
they continue to announce people they're
looking for I'll do videos because
they're going to do all kinds of comic
book stuff they're doing justice society
they're doing Superman on Supergirl of
course there's going to be a whole bunch
of new big comic book characters on the
flash season 3 so moving into the comics
though flash rebirth if you haven't had
a chance to check it out just careful
for spoilers I'm going to be explaining
who the villain is Godspeed in kind of
what the story is that they're teeing up
so what happened is is the comic that
debuted this week flash rebirth is kind
of like a prelude to the flash storyline
that's going to be running for the rest
of the issues so it just introduced you
to the characters gave you an idea
for what all their relationships are
like Barry Allen seems like he's dating
iris they're not married it follows up
on the post-crisis return of wally west
from that last issue where it was like
oh my god he just came out of the Speed
Force how'd you get here we start to
cross over with the other titles so like
the big mystery the big dr. Manhattan
mystery of why he stole all those years
from everyone is going to be the master
art but the story for the flash comic
like the main story for the flash comic
will be this giant speed for storm that
gives a whole bunch of new people powers
Barry has to mentor them and in the pre
Lou this week he starts to have visions
of things in the future he sees you Bart
dawn has a very familiar reaction to him
he sees godspeed saying I'm gonna kill
them all but he doesn't really
understand what it's all about so you
really just get flashes of things that
are going to be happening later this
year but the story of the issue like the
self-contained story of the issue is a
little girl's parents being murdered in
a very similar way to Barry Allen's
mother being murdered Barry takes a
special interest in it because it's so
similar to his mother's murder he tries
to help out then later in the issue as
he's running by the crime scene again he
hears two detectives talk in one of the
mentions how the father confessed in
very Allen makes mistakes sometimes so I
think based on that idea that God speed
will be collateral damage for some
mistake that Barry made Barry tries to
do something good but it leads to
something bad happening in that bad
thing causes Godspeed to become Godspeed
so just to reiterate what's going on in
the comics with godspeed has absolutely
nothing to do with the TV show the
current rumor for the flash season three
is that the villain won't even be a
metahuman so all the rebirth stuff has
nothing to do with what's going on in
the TV shows but it's a really awesome
issue there's some nice easter eggs if
you've been reading the flash for a long
time like you read mark waid flash if
you read Silver Age flash there's easter
eggs for all that stuff flash fact
remember the time you almost destroyed
creation yeah flashpoint that was so
much fun giveaway time that
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner kyle scott you in a twenty dollar
amazon gift card you can use it to buy
all the rebirth comics that you want on
comiXology or wherever else so be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so i can get your contact
details that's just on the about page so
i'll start a new round of the giveaway
whenever I post my next DC video
wait guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here for my injustice to
trailer video and you can click here for
my Suicide Squad Batman teaser thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you